thank you
this image of the Vitruvian Man taken
from Leonardo sketches has become one of
the most recognizable symbols of the
Renaissance but why
it's a simple pen and ink drawing right
wrong
let's start to answer this question with
a math problem
I know how to calculate the area of a
circle and take the value for pi and
multiply it by the radius squared I also
know how to take the area of a square I
multiply the base by itself
but how can I take the area of a circle
and create a square with an equal area
this is a problem often called squaring
a circle that was first proposed in the
ancient world and like many ideas of the
ancient world it was given new life
during the Renaissance as it turns out
this problem is impossible to solve
because of the nature of Pi
but that's another story Leonardo sketch
which is influenced by the writings of
the Roman architect Vitruvius places a
man firmly at the center of a circle and
a square retruvius claimed the naval is
the center of the human body and that if
one takes a compass and places the fixed
point on the navel a circle can be drawn
perfectly around the body additionally
Vitruvius recognize that arm span and
height have a nearly perfect
correspondence in the human body thus
placing the body perfectly inside a
square as well Leonardo used the ideas
of Vitruvius to solve the problem of
squaring a circle metaphorically using
mankind as the area for both shapes
Leonardo wasn't just thinking about
Vitruvius though there was an
intellectual movement in Italy at the
time called neoplatonism this movement
took an old concept from the 4th Century
developed by Plato and Aristotle called
the Great chain of being this belief
holds that the Universe has a hierarchy
resembling a chain and that chain starts
at the top with God then travels down
through the Angels planets stars and all
life forms before ending with demons and
Devils early in this philosophic
movement it was thought that Mankind's
place in this chain was exactly in the
center because humans have a mortal body
accompanied by an immortal Soul we
divide the universe nicely in half
around the time Leonardo sketched the
retruvian man however a neoplatonist
named Pico de la mirandola had a
different idea he pried mankind off the
chain and claimed that humans have a
unique ability to take any position they
want Pico claimed that God desire to be
incapable of comprehending the beautiful
and complicated Universe he had created
this led to the creation of mankind
which he placed at the center of the
universe with the ability to take
whatever form he pleases mankind
according to Pico could crawl down the
chain and behave like an animal or crawl
up the chain and behave like a god it's
our choice looking back at the sketch we
can see that by changing the position of
the man he can feel the irreconcilable
areas of a circle and a square if
geometry is a language the universe is
written in then this sketch seems to say
we can exist within all its elements
mankind can fill whatever shape he
pleases geometrically and
philosophically as well in this one
sketch Leonardo was able to combine the
mathematics religion philosophy
architecture and artistic skill of his
age no wonder it's become such an icon
for the entire time period
foreign